A
SYSTEM TO BETTER SERVE KIDS.
LAWRENCE: PANEL IS HERE, TONY
AND KEVIN ARE BOTH HERE --
TONY GOIL TO YOU FIRST WE'VE
SEEN A SHIFT IN THIS RACE.
MANDELA BARNES WAS NOW DOWN BY
SIX POINTS AND A LOT OF FOLKS
SAY IT'S BECAUSE OF THE ISSUE OF
CRIME.
>> YES.
THE WHOLE DEFUND THE POLICE
CONVERSATION AND WE'VE HEARD
MANY TIMES LOOK AT WHAT THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT HAS DONE.
LOOK AT LEGISLATION PASSED AND
LOOK AT THE MONEY THAT'S BEEN
SPENT THEY SAID DEFUND POLICE
AND IT STUCK IT AND
REPRESENTATIVE CORY BUSH SAID
JUST LAST WEEK PEOPLE SAY USED
TERM REALLOCATE AND MOVE THE
MONEY BUT IT IS ALL THE SAME
THING THEY ACTUALLY BELIEVE IN
NOT HAVING A POLICE FORCE ON THE
GROUND THAT DOES THE JOB THAT
DON'T BELIEVE IN PURSUING
CRIMINALS THAT'S WHAT JOHN
FEDDER MAN IN PENNSYLVANIA SAID
WHEN HE WAS LEAST ENGAGING IN
SOME CONVERSATIONS.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
THEY PUT IT OUT THERE.
IT IS STATISTIC AND THEY'RE
UPSET THAT IT IS.
>> KEVIN WHAT ABOUT THAT
REACTION FROM PANEL THERE THAT I
HAD --
EVERYONE HAD TO ADMIT SCREEL A
MAJOR ISSUE.
>> YEAH LAWRENCE I LOVE THE
PANEL FROM MILWAUKEE KEEP ME IN
TOUCH WITH KATHY WE NEED TO USE
HER IN TV ADS COMING UP BUT
LISTEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT ACTUAL
POLICE FUNDING AND WHO'S
ACTUALLY INCREASING BUDGETSES
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE
BOARD IN ALL OF THESE
COMMUNITIES, IT IS DEMOCRATS WE
DEVOTED 350 BILLION DOLLARS PART
OF THE RESCUE PLAN THAT WENT IN
MANY WAYS DIRECTLY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HIRE MORE COPS TO
HIRE MORE COPS BACK.
WE JUST PASSED A POLICE REFORM
PACKAGE TWO WEEKS AGO TO
DECREASE FUNDING SO WHEN YOU
WELCOME AT WHAT IS LEGISLATED
ESPECIALLY ON THE NATIONAL
LEVEL, IT IS BY PRESIDENT BIDEN
THE DEMOCRATS WORKING SINGLE
HANDEDLY TO INCREASE THESE FUNDS
WOW.
>> GO AHEAD KEVIN REAL QUICK.
>> THIS IS MADDENING ARGUMENT
KEVIN BECAUSE YOU KEEP PUSHING
SAME ARGUMENT AND IT IS LOVELY
BUT IT ISN'T TRUE IN THE CITIES.
THE CITIES ARE RUN BY THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT.
THE PROSECUTORS DON'T PROSECUTE.
THE COPS FEEL HAM STRUNG THEY
RYE TO DEFUND AND REALIZE IT
DIDN'T WORK AND TRY TO PUT MONEY
BACK BUT ATTITUDE IS THE SAME.
AND THAT CAN'T GO AWAY AND IT IS
A PLAYER IN MIDTERMS.
LAWRENCE: I WANT TO MOVE ON --
>> TONY YOU WANT TO PLAY
POLITICS WITH THIS SEVEN STATES
WITH HIGHEST MURDER RATES IN
THIS COUNTRY ARE STATES THAT
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP THIS IS A
PROBLEM ACROSS THE BOARD, IT'S
NOT JUST INNER CITIES WE NEED TO
BE HONEST WITH AMERICAN PEOPLE
AS AFFECTING RURAL AREAS
SUBURBAN AREA AND ONE PARTY
THAT'S RYING TO INCREASE FUNDING
RIGHT NOW IN CONGRESS --
>> YOU'RE PARTY THAT SAYS DEFUND
HOW DARE YOU BE UPSET FOR ME FOR
NOTICING.
>> AS A DEMOCRAT AND LEADER OF
MY PARTY.
>> FOR THAT TO BE TRUE.
>> LIVE THAT LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE NO ONE IN HIS PARTY WANTS
TO CAMPAIGN FOR HIM AND NOW YOU
HAVE WARNOCK SAYING THIS WATCH
THE PASTOR.
>> I'VE NOT SPENT A MINUTE
THINKING ABOUT --
WHAT POLITICIAN SHOULD RUN FOR
WHAT IN 2024.
>> YOU HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT IT
IF YOU CAN IN 2024 THE PRESIDENT
WILL TURN 82 YEARS OLD.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT HIS
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL FITNESS YOU
HAVE 30 SECONDS.
>> THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA HIRED
ME TO REPRESENT THEM REGARDLESS
OF WHO IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
LAWRENCE: SO HE JUST CAN'T
PREACH HE CAN SPIN AND HE DOES
NOT WANT TO BE IN CONNECTION
WITH THE PRESIDENT KEVIN, WHY?
>> WELL HE'S ONE OF THEM AND WE
SAW THIS ON THE RIGHT WITH
DONALD TRUMP AND NOT ACCOUNT TO
GO TO SUBURBS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT HE HAS TO POX ON GEORGIA
AND RACE TO WIN IN NOW 24 DAYS
FROM NOW EARLY VOTING STARTS IN
THE PEACH STATE ON MONDAY.
BUT LISTEN THE PRESIDENT IS ON
CAMPAIGN SWING RIGHT NOW OUT IN
OREGON WHICH IS ACTUALLY AN
INTERESTINGLY TIGHT RACE WITH A
REPUBLICAN CHALLENGER FOR THAT
GOVERNOR SEAT.
THAT'S OVER PRMPLEG HE WAS IN
COLORADO IN A TIGHT SENATE RACE
OUT THERE WITH MICHAEL BENNETT
SO CRISS-CROSS COUNTRY THIS IS
ONE PARTICULAR RACE IN GEORGIA
BUT YOU SEE PRESIDENT OUT THERE
IF FULL STEAM AHEAD CAMPAIGNING
UP AND DOWN BALLOT FOR
DEMOCRATS.
LOOK FELLAS I HAVE TO GO BUT
I'LL TELL YOU THIS LAST TIME I
CHECKED PEOPLE WANTED TO
CAMPAIGN WITH TRUMP.
THEY WANTED TO CAMPAIGN WITH
BARACK OBAMA BILL CLINTON,
JOCI